here at cbs we're very committed to
stopping the stigma surrounding
mental health the world health
organization says that covet has created
what they call a parallel pandemic when
it comes to mental health
a new survey found that u.s adults have
the highest stress levels since april
84 reported feeling at least one emotion
associated with prolonged stress like
anxiety sadness and anger so we asked
our instagram followers to share the
first word that pops into your mind
when you think about mental health
during this pandemic their responses
include
exhausted lonely overwhelmed forgotten
can i add the word enough to that list
too psychiatrist dr sue varma
joins us now so what would be your one
word i'm curious
dumpster fire oh my gosh no yeah that
sums it up
so when we talk about these parallel
mental health
this parallel pandemic what is the
impact what does it mean exactly you
know
we really have to help people address
the mental health issues because it
affects um
their ability to be a parent their
ability to be productive in the
workforce
um we're finding that people are
experiencing trauma you know and
and trauma you know we could talk call
it with a big t
or trauma with the little t in in the
sense that we've lost
lives um there's a lot of grieving going
on grieving is not only the things that
we lost but it's also the things that we
didn't get to have we didn't get to
commemorate important milestones we
didn't get to grieve losses
in person during funerals so we really
need to look at the
economic impact as well and i think that
that's you know a really big part of the
picture
so i think a lot of people aren't really
even fully conscious of how deeply they
may have been affected by everything in
the past year
how do you know that the toll it's
taking and how do you give yourself kind
of a mental health checkup
exactly so you know it's very
interesting because tony we've been
talking about mental health issues since
the beginning of the pandemic and
it goes in waves and it goes in stages
and the more
layers of losses that a person
experiences of jobs
economic losses and then add in the
uncertainty the fact that we thought
this was going to be at
lockdown in march of last year a
two-week thing and here we are almost a
year later
so it's really important to understand
that there are layers upon the stress
and there's unrelenting stress and
chronic stress
and ask yourself a certain key questions
if you can look at over the last two
weeks to one month
how has your mood been has your mood
been lower than usual are you
experiencing more anxiety than usual
are you having trouble sleeping and are
you having morbid thoughts that life is
not worth living the hopelessness and
the pessimism that's one thing that i
see setting in
in people the longer that this goes on
yeah i so agree with anthony sue i can't
wait till they drill down and really
look at the effect that this has had on
all of us because we just sort of plow
through
but i know that you have some easy what
you call mental health
exercises that we can all do such as yes
and you know gail yes one of them is a
progressive muscle relaxation i think
that it's so important that people be
able to take breaks so one thing i want
to say is take breaks during the day
and this is one easy exercise that you
can do two to three times
a day in addition to having breaks
between separation between your work and
your home life so i could say if you
could go for a walk
great and if you can't this is something
that you could do at your desk and i'm
wondering if you'd be willing to try
this on uh with me right now and i'd
love to have you experiment with it
um you know progressive muscle
relaxation means you sit back in your
chair
and you know look this is not going to
take the place this is not a substitute
for
mental health treatment but these are
things that you can do by yourself
so you close your eyes you settle in
your chair and you let your shoulders
relax
and you take a deep breath and you
clench your fists the idea is that you
are
tensing and releasing muscle muscle
group by muscle group
so open and close my eyes open and close
my fist
is that what you're saying open and
close your fist yes yes so just settle
down in the chair
close your eyes let your shoulders relax
and then breathe with me
and you're clenching your fist and
they're by your side and i'm just
keeping them up here so you can see but
you're clenching your fists
and then you're releasing them and then
you're clenching them again
and you're releasing them and you're
taking in a deep breath
what is this doing for me what is it
doing and what
what this is doing this is relaxing and
this is invoking your
parasympathetic system what's happening
is we're all in fight or flight mode we
are waiting for the next shoe to drop if
the other shoe hasn't dropped
and this is the vagal tone in the body
really creates the relaxation and it
says that like i'm not in
a war zone you know when we look at the
economic impact gail i didn't even get
to talk about how this is costing the
united states
200 billion dollars a year absenteeism
presenteeism
you're right so showing up to work
showing up and not being able to be
present
we can all do that close your eyes and
open and close your fists thank you sue
varma always good to see you
feeling stressed right now because i
gotta go
we'll be right back